más de 12 millones de shanghainés es
casi la mitad de la población pueden
pisar en la calle después de un mes son
los que viven en las zonas de prevención
o de bajo riesgo es decir aquellas en
las que no se ha detectado ni un solo
contagio en la comunidad en las dos
últimas semanas la medida llega después
de que el número de contagios haya caído
de forma paulatina hasta estabilizarse
por debajo de los 10.000 cuando no hace
tanto tiempo superaban los 20 mil y
mientras tanto aquí en beijing la
mayoría de la población pasaba hoy por
su tercera prueba en cinco días estos
tests masivos no han revelado el temido
brote extendido que había hecho pensar
el fin de semana en un inminente
confinamiento hoy se ha informado de
apenas 49 casos y sin embargo las
restricciones siguen aumentando
especialmente en el distrito céntrico de
chaoyang que suma la mayoría de los
casos ahí se han cerrado escuelas
lugares turísticos y de ocio
nadie quiere aquí en china repetir la
calamitosa demora de shanghai ahora las
medidas se toman de inmediato en
guangzhou la macro ciudad del sur
se han ordenado test masivos y se han
cancelado vuelos después de haberse
detectado un posible contagio el
aeropuerto y sin ni siquiera haber
esperado a que quedara confirmado